well we will live in a world that is  changing drastically and then we cannot  remain where we were fifty years ago we  can I just be defenders for the status  quo or the old cultures I think in a  certain Kaka God who said that life is  understood backwards and it's lived  forward so we can go back and look at  the things that our forebears did and  did them well and emulate them today at  the same time we have to move forward in  this world of science and technology  which are rapidly changing our lives for  much better production much better  prosperity and more I have everywhere  you go today physical toll has been  replaced by mental effort automation  computers have replaced human memory and  judgment after contraction know about  computers information technology so  major  we need to emulate what this university  has done educating many people in  different countries